my guest tonight is an academy
award-nominated actor and
golden globe winner he's appeared in
dozens of memorable films like boogie
nights crash hotel rwanda
iron man 2 and 3 and the avengers movies
good lord he also stars in the fantastic
showtime series
black monday which just began streaming
its third
season please welcome the accomplished
the extremely busy
uh gentleman don cheadle wow
that's a lot that's a lot of stuff you
know what um
i you did not have any facial hair when
i started reading your credits
that's how long it took you grew yeah
you grew up full on
beer it's the picture of don cheadle
gray
thanks for being here in person i have
to say
i had an experience i i we were choking
around before
uh we started taping about how much
people love you
and um i was at having dinner with my
wife and my son was there
and uh this is quite a while ago but you
were sitting at another table
and we went over and we said a quick hi
and you were very nice to my son and my
son freaked out and he does not freak
out about celebrities
but on the drive home it was that was
don cheadle that was don cheadle
avengers just losing his mind to the
point
where i became enraged i became
jealous i will pull this car over
and pull out my resume on youtube i will
tell you some of the things i didn't
like i know what you've done
it's no don cheadle and it was uh
yes so you ruined my nights i think it's
your fault for coming over
i think i shouldn't you could have just
walked right out i tried to
i tried to just dash out and my son was
like that's don cheadle we have
we gotta go say hi to don cheadle yeah
yeah but thank you so much for being
here glad to be here you know andy jump
in at any moment if you want to say
anything kind about don cheadle who's
beloved
or or anything andy tell me anything you
can do some of that hatred that you were
doing before
we started hatred it's called
constructive criticism
it's a standard thing we've been
doing here for 28 years on the on this
versions of the late night show which is
just before we talk to someone
andy gives them a lot of really strong
constructive criticism
that comes across as hate and then we go
action and we start the interview and i
think it helps that's right
well that's right shouldn't constructive
criticism give you the ability to
somehow fix it it's just not like
you're just don cheadle and you suck
it's like
what can i do how can i fix that yeah
but i mean i can only lead you to water
you got to drink yourself
you know what's great uh obviously
you've had such an incredible
career and uh and i'm acting like it
we're wrapping it up your career
um uh you are uh you're just killing it
out there all the time
but you know i'm always impressed with
you're such a
very and it's not maybe the first thing
people would think of but you're so
naturally
funny you're a very funny guy and i
always notice that when we chat and
when i bump into you and i thought
has he ever used that before earlier in
his life and then i found out that you
tried
stand up in high school what was your
act like
i foolishly did do that um i was with a
friend who is as
ridiculous as i was and we thought we
could probably do this we were driving
by
larimer square i think the comedy is a
comedy store or there's some right
place spot there and they had an open
mic night and it was friday night and we
had just had a week of
whatever at school and we thought you
know what we're theater geeks we could
probably
do this so we went back to my house and
we had a bunch of you know
cards and died we we our humor was like
we diagnosed the humor of nancy the
comic strip nancy
we're just saying nancy and sluggo
that's right the
the comic that no one has ever really
been able i think
henry bush miller did that comic and it
doesn't make sense no
it's objectively unfunny there's nothing
funny
about it so we diagnosed the humor of
nancy for everybody it explained why it
was indeed
hilarious we did uh a series of pope
francis jokes with him on the
and a bishop holding his hat
while he told the worst jokes in the
world okay
great great so you have the material
let's see
you had the material we had the material
i don't know how but we had it
and we went back that night and you know
we're too young to be in the club we're
17 years old
uh but we did it and it was great and we
had it worked
it worked wow so the club owner was like
okay why don't you guys come back next
friday we're gonna have another open mic
see how you like it just try it out so
we
did and worked up a bunch of other
material and
uh a game show where you know if you got
the answers wrong the consequences were
deadly not just
you know like right reaching the bag and
get bit by an asp it was like stuff like
that right
uh killed again i was like this is
incredible
this was incredible you could have had
an amazing career and
what happened here then we did it again
oh yeah
i know you already know okay it's the
third time there you go
what happened the third time well uh in
front of an invited audience of family
and friends
and and others uh it didn't go as well
um and the collective sound of
individual
people groaning with a groan that like
it was pretty bad yeah so we we bombed
and i've never felt anything that
horrible it's bombing on stage
and stan there's nowhere to hide there's
nowhere to pass the ball you just have
to stand there
you're praying that the time is is up
really quickly you can't walk off
it was just bad i don't know what you're
talking about
never happened to you you know what i
always say is when you can hear the air
conditioning
that when i can hear the air
conditioning and sometimes it gets so
quiet you can hear
cells dividing in people
and uh it is the most horrible thing is
so
that night and it's interesting because
your first two times
you're killing it yeah and then it's
that third time where this sort of
reality sets in if this is not what it
will always be like
right yes this is not what it will be
like for the next three minutes while
you have to stand up here
and it was so bad it's like you know on
the way home my parents didn't talk
about it at all we talked about other
things right i
didn't mention it like yeah that that's
that's that's not that's that's death
when you get in a car after a show and
people that were there
don't say anything no they just say so
we want to get something to eat
exactly let's just move on to you can we
talk about what just happened back there
i don't i don't think i don't think so i
don't think you want that
do you come from a funny uh family is
your mom funny mom was funny
dad was funny mom was you know mom was
funny slash dangerous it's like you know
my mom
grew up and both my parents are from
small towns in midwest but
my mom grew up in kind of a bad area and
uh when she was young she actually
carried a gun she carried a little
38 that oh wow i found going through her
stuff and you know i gingerly asked her
about the gun you know and she said oh
yeah i've had that gun for a long time i
cared it when i was young but i
had to stop carrying it and i said why
she said because excuse me turned into
move
i was like okay
that is some experience i'm just going
through mom's purse
oh lipstick and compact and 38 38
i guess i'm going to listen when mom
asked me to do something
you know um think i was just thinking
right now there's this image i think
about this often
one of my favorite sort of funny images
that comes to mind
sometimes is in boogie nights when your
character is trying a new look
oh yeah and you have the yeah the the
wig
and this i forget what the what the knit
was a was it i think it's kind of earth
wind and fire
and you look you're alone at a party and
you're despondent
wearing that outfit and it's it's just
such a great
there's so much comedy in that moment
and sadness
it's at the same time that moment in
fact was
so pta paul thomas anderson who directed
that
so i get in the get up i'm sitting there
and he comes over and he says okay now
in this moment i just want
i just want nothing i just want nothing
nothing happening
i was like nothing i don't know okay so
we shoot it
okay cut he comes over he goes you were
kind of doing
nothing i just want nothing like nothing
i'm like
nothing he's like yeah just just give me
nothing
i'm sitting there trying to figure out
this it was like a japanese koan you
know i'm like
trying to figure out what he means yeah
and he comes back he goes okay got it
thanks so while you were trying to
figure out his direction he got with you
yeah he rolled on the camera you know
that scene i'm talking about andy it's
just it's
i i i there's so much i love that movie
but there's this
uh you're you sitting there
totally despondent uh and i feel like
yeah
i've been there many times in my life i
haven't been wearing this
i've been wearing that wig i've probably
been wearing another wig or another
costume
but i've been totally like my soul has
left my body yeah
and and it was such a brilliant way for
him to
to get at that because the direction was
baffling yeah and i think when i look at
it that's the look on it on my
there's just nothing in there it's like
some empty vessel
like why am i in this movie why did i
let
him talk me into this that would have
been a perfect time to think about nancy
comics
yeah yeah exactly yeah exactly that's a
callback
yeah the um i got to ask you yeah
i got to ask you about uh you know no
i'm sure you're not allowed to talk
about it
but you are in the space jam reboot
yep and that means you've been working
with lebron james
this is true now i know i'm not allowed
to ask about like specifics about the
project
but lebron james is one of those people
where i have to think
uh what kind of energy is it you've
worked with all these
top actors but you're working with
someone who literally
has the title like king king james and
he is revered and he is this force of
nature
what's it like working with him
in the uh while acting just it was it
was great actually i mean he really did
approach it like a team player he really
did approach it like
he would approach the sport because he
didn't have it i mean he's done a couple
he did train wreck
and he's done a couple other things
where he really still
you know thinks of it as a sport
in many ways right and as he does
in the game he was like always there
always ready
always prepared ready to try something
ready to just go
all in and at some point i was like you
know you could be a much bigger diva
than your being right now you are king
james yeah yeah
but he was just always the only time
that he really required
special treatment is when that huge
human being had to eat
so there would be certain times he'd be
like oh gotta eat
and we would sit there and wait for 15
minutes when he would and what would he
eat he's not just having like a tic tac
and a diet soda no it was usually tissue
paper
and he's very concerned about his
physique
no i mean he would eat whatever his
person would bring out but it would be
you know substantial and he would sit
there
and eat and yeah we'd have to sit and
wait and i was like i'm going to start
doing that
that's important we don't do that enough
we don't
we don't focus on you know because
you've been on set you know what it's
like you know you work 14-hour days
sometimes
and if you don't really take care of
yourself by the end of that thing you
could be done
and he was you know nursing an injury
he was still putting the team together
at that time sometimes after we shoot
he'd go do practice sometimes before we
chewed it at practice
so i can't it was a grueling schedule
for him so what you're advocating
is that at any moment i should just say
i can stop anything
and say i need to eat and and then a
giant you know rack of lamb is brought
out you're current o'brien
i can't believe that it took this for
you to to figure that out are you hungry
now
not really
but if you would i don't like lamb i'm
not really a lamb guy
right see it's falling apart oh it
already isn't working and also it's not
gonna work i'm going to say hey i need
to eat and they're going to say well
it's going to be 40 minutes to get the
olive garden to deliver
oh it's the olive garden that's your
go-to yeah bread just
just a big old bed that's going to
impress the big old basket of friends
you uh you know before we we started
talking you were checking out there's a
guitar there's a guitar back there and i
know that you're a very
uh you're a very well-trained jazz
musician that's fair to say you actually
you know your stuff i i studied it
very hard in high school and when i was
you know
trying to figure out what i was going to
do in my life music was
one of the options that i was
considering but
you know being such an aficionado of the
music
and really a student of it and
probably mixed with some amount of
uh neuroses and and a
lack of confidence in that area i kind
of didn't want to pursue it because i
just knew what shedding
as a musician was going to be to get to
where i wanted to get
you know when my musical heroes are
miles and charlie parker and cannonball
adeline like i'm
shooting like that going i'm going to
have to really dedicate
my entire life to this focus
and it was you know music is
kind of elusive to a brain that doesn't
like get math
sometimes you know what i mean there's a
lot of structure in it that
i would sometimes just go into a fog i
was have a great ear had a great ear
could always fake my way around stuff
but i was like
if i'm gonna really have to dig into
theory the amount of time i'm gonna have
to take
i think i'm just gonna be an actor
i think you made it i think you made a
good choice first of all it's worked out
pretty well it's i'm doing all right
yeah you're doing kind of okay
um but do you ever do you play music now
do you ever
do you play jazz in your in your free
time i do
i do i've started to you know pick up
the base a few years ago
and it's great to just i mean they're
beautiful right it's great to just have
them sitting around
on the stand you have 20 30 minutes just
pick it up and like
get into it so i've been doing that uh a
lot do you do vocal stuff do you ever do
vocal jazz stuff
i haven't i mean i sing just to mess
around but that's when i was
uh in high school that's basically what
we did that was mainly one of the things
i did i had scholarships i was fortunate
enough to get scholarships to
attend universities and study vocal jazz
and jazz that was going to be my
my metier i have never studied uh vocal
jazz in any way
but it's one of those things i know that
i would master immediately
you i get that from you you have vocal
jazz vibes coming off of you
thank you in waves i've never been more
serious about anything in my life
i just i i and i don't mean i know it
sounds arrogant what i'm saying
oh it does it's just a statement of fact
that i can just yeah i can just touch
you could just give me
uh you know is that piano tuned i mean
you might you hit a g
or give you just a can you give me a g
you know give me a g
over there and i'm gonna give you thank
you very much just give me a g
[Music]
set up today
oh
i thought there was a pinterest you know
there was a little more i knew there was
more that was more gas
than anything else yeah yeah so
that's just something i don't like to
talk about a lot but
i could see why
i think it's time to wrap this up this
is that moment
this is that moment that we foresaw i
really enjoyed watching your face during
that
[Laughter]
it was amazing it was a return to your
boogie night's performance you looked
completely lost and just been filming my
soul
i was bereft of spirit at that moment
let me ask you about
uh let me ask you about black monday uh
this program has been it started out in
the 80s
okay and we're talking about going
through this this massive
and a lot of people watching right now
young people don't know that in 1987
biggest stock market crash of all time
occurred i remembered i was just
starting in the business
uh out here in l.a and it happened and
people were wondering
are atms going to just stop working
are we all going to be around burning
trash cans you know hunting for
food we didn't know it was that dramatic
at the time
of course it didn't turn out to be that
but it was
a massive stock market crash yeah it
wiped out a lot of people
wiped out a lot of people and um
that is really what your show has been
centered around but now
you're in this is the third season third
season
so you're in the 90s we're moving into
the 90s toward the end of it
um kind of it will not to give away
anything but it kind of that's where
we're that's where we're trending
toward it uh at the in the 90s and you
know at this point
dawn's character uh don played by regina
hall
she's been in jail for trading insider
trading for
the black monday crash my character has
been has been a part of so many
nefarious trades he's lost his license
it's like we can't really
be in that business anymore so they're
trying to figure out
what do they do now and how do they you
know matriculate
into the real world and right and still
behave badly
and still use their skills as horrible
people
to impress upon the world but at least
now you're getting into the music of the
90s the style of the 90s
you know yeah which is a lot of fun i
mean that's always the most fun on the
show
is the the commentary that we get to do
you know about today really dealing
with that time period and that's always
the fun is how to to play with those
sort of cultural
uh uh mores and the things that uh
we're really reminded of during that
time to see how far we really haven't
come
in many ways well i'm just going to put
this out there and you can talk to
you know the creators and producers and
stuff but andy and i started
uh our show in 1993.
so if you want andy we could get made up
to look like ourselves
almost 30 years ago wow and we could
come on as ourselves your characters
could bump into us and be like wow
conan o'brien andy richter you just
started the late night show
why do you guys look like you're in your
50s lately
that's what we would ask that we'd be
like wow what's wrong with you or you
yeah yeah
but we'd have to explain why we don't
look 30 and you know 27 that's how old
we were when we started
we'd have to write in something like we
got really bad food poisoning and then
we got
radiation uh blasted and we could do a
chernobyl
like a church yeah yes yeah this is this
guy this has potential
yeah yeah tv subtracts 30 years
it adds 10 pounds and uh yeah it
subtracts you yeah yeah
you're also i mean talk about your as i
said you're absurdly busy you're
narrating the reboot of the wonder
years yeah that's a pretty cool gig yeah
that is
i mean uh the i we've just shot the
pilot
um and it's really cute and fred savage
is still involved
um and he it's great to have him there
and you know
have this touchstone to the past and i
think it really
keeps the same spirit of the show it's
just it's it's been live
and fred savage is still playing a child
he which and he still looks like a child
he could come on and there would be no
difference
except he grew he'd just be taller but
he looks exactly the same he does like
he always kept that child like
boyish thing yeah yeah sort of elfin um
you also uh new movie that you're in
that's coming out directed by a
little-known director
named steven soderbergh that's the guy
who's finally caught a break
uh and and this uh film is called no
sudden move what can you tell us about
that
uh no sudden move is a noir film set in
1955 detroit it was actually the first
movie
that came back pretty close to being the
first movie that came back
after all the pandemic stuff that shut
everything down which i blame stephen
for because he
directed contagion and there you go i
think he put it into the world let's be
honest
i say he's patient zero
but we shouted in detroit uh last year
and uh
we're gonna be the centerpiece for the
tribeca film festival the juice is
fantastic
it's kind of cool we're really looking
forward to it we have a clip here we're
going to show from no sudden move
anything you can tell us
for this clip um it's amazing you guys
aren't in it
that's not why it's amazing
but um uh i think this is my character
kind of um
dealing with the the the setup this is
what we're about to deal with all right
let's take a look at this clip from no
sudden move
mister you mind sitting up front
i do
i'd like to sit in the back this is
ridiculous we're wasting time
be my guest
kurt meet ronald ronald
kurt
[Music]
i love it all his the hair too yeah
absolutely incredible
amazing yeah um first of all
i would love i would love being i mean
i'm not an actor but if i was in a
period film
i would just love getting to wear those
clothes it really didn't drive around in
those cars and you probably start to
feel like yeah it's 1955.
100 100 and the great thing about
detroit
you know good and bad i mean it's
there's elements of detroit that haven't
really moved
on in ways since then in the
neighborhoods that you can go to and
kind of see
um the same architecture it's one of the
few places like that i think cincinnati
is another one
uh where you can shoot and kind of still
feel like you're you're back then
right and all the great car stuff in
detroit you know it's the mecca
it was it was a lot of fun and very
scary to be back on a set
that soon after everything but stephen
really uh you know he wrote the
protocols for the dga and he really
protected everybody and we didn't have
any incidents so we were very fortunate
in that yeah
it does seem i mean unless i'm wrong but
it feels like on in television
and uh in movies they've really got
their together
and figured out a way to keep people
safe because there's been a lot so much
work's been done and
people have you know for the most part
people for the most part overwhelmingly
have been safe yeah it's fantastic yeah
black monday we got through without any
stops you know uh we were very fortunate
in that too
so it's it's you just have to take it
seriously and it's real
and it's not a joke and you know it's
it's it's something that we can do if
everybody behaves so yeah
well uh make sure i get the word out
black monday air
sundays at 10 on showtime no sudden move
will be available on hbo
max july 1st don
every time i talk to you i'm reminded
what a great guy you are what a
gentleman
how talented don cheadle thank you so
much for being here thank you
glad to be here